in Europe demand for SUVs continues
unabated so it's little wonder that Ford
is out to grab a piece of the action
with its second generation kuga the new
model looks fresher and more dynamic
together with Germany's Auto Club a DAC
we're taking a closer look at the Kouga
from the inside that's because it's not
just the vehicles exterior that's been
given an overhaul the engines are new
too I'm proven too big for that margin
Hodor fur from the ABAC points out that
cou this 140 horsepower 4-cylinder
engine and that's with its 320 newton
meters of torque it produces adequate
power it is pleasantly quiet the Kouga
also aims to please when it comes to
fuel economy and our tests it consumes
six point six liters of diesel per 100
kilometers that's fairly decent for an
SUV but is higher than the manufacturers
fuel economy figures
once a test box the engineer says our
test cars equipped with all-wheel drive
an advantage in snowy or slippery
conditions but the Kouga is not really
enough rotor in his opinion at six speed
transmission suits the engine and the
suspension is well tuned and thanks to
Ford's curve control and torque
vectoring control systems the Kouga can
easily navigate obstacles the compact
SUV has a braking distance of 36 meters
from a speed of 100 kilometers an hour
but first and foremost an SUV should be
practical and the CUDA is its variable
trunk space can hold between 445 and 890
liters of cargo with a flat cargo floor
drivers who have their hands full but
have a second to spare will appreciate
the automatic trunk opener
and to close it you can always use your
foot
the wide c-pillars spoil the view a
little and while the Cougars cabin bus
quality workmanship it's a little too
busy the seats are very comfy fine
family life never mean EAC thinks the
new CUDA is a vehicle for young
fashion-conscious families it offers
plenty of space for work and play and
look sporting and he says the price is
right our test vehicle with titanium
trim that sells for just over 31,000
euros the Ford Coogan has a starting
price of just under twenty five thousand
euros in Germany
you